it's gonna be fine okay I trust you guys
Ivo God what the [ __ ]
god I'm breakfast
come on toast
come on Chuck there's a video I want to
show you Save the Children is doing a
campaign for the refugees in Syria
I want you bros to go to help is coming
org check it out buy the song and pass
it forward thank you Oh ma'am
I broke the toilet America can handle my
[ __ ] pigs the Builder can he fix it yeah
yes he can put some clothes on just for
some little candy for your ladies you
know you like it I got a lot of work to
do this morning and Mia MRSA going out
and then I'm doing another crazy day and
I feel like I didn't even have enough
time to process what happened yesterday
so things are hectic
and I just dropped my towel all right
ladies you're doing that you to life
answering emails all day
what where are we going
Bart is long did really well I'm really
happy everyone is like if you don't want
to vlog then don't but of course we love
to see your blogs every day enjoying
tree um that's very nice but I'm not on
holiday I see a lot of cute people think
I'm a holiday
I'm here to work alright yesterday
I'm blocking traffic yesterday was so
hot today is nice I like la yay we can't
withdraw money here I don't understand
Oh also someone said boots got a snap
what are these called tattoos and chain
besides I think he's getting like a
midlife crisis
uh-oh gotta click no dammit
that is like hello fellow gangsters I
think we're the only walking people in
LA right now head stop daydreaming blood
orange sweet Chi yes hallelujah
hallelujah but 15 minutes walk to get
groceries alright cool
I like how vegetables comes last in
America when it's first everywhere else
hey you know that feeling you have when
you're really nervous about something
that you got to do that feeling in your
gut that just won't go away
I'm really really nervous for what we're
going to do is today hi because I don't
know what we're doing and I hope I can
just get through it I honestly don't
know why nice one dude YouTube comments
who else kissed his screen at the end
when pills kissed the camera I was just
like ill make up your mind [ __ ]
my work today starts in an hour I'm just
gonna chill in the meanwhile and charge
up it's gonna be a long day I got the
new update for the game and I thought we
check it out there's a lot of other
youtubers in the game which is something
that you bros really requested whoo kids
they be hmm could that be markiplier
could that be cinnamon tears can could
that be jacksepticeye and cry and whom
who is that you can unlock the
characters when you beat certain levels
in the game they all did voice acting
for the game and I did as well of course
and this is the first time I will hear
them how they sound like using your bun
cheeks so anyways thanks for watching
and as always stay awesome it's awesome
I wonder how many views my last video
guy this is not bad but it feels weird
might say you should watch belong to us
and now it's your turn to be contained
it's my sass lines are coming up are you
nervous
you been good we went to an actual
studio to record these alright it's
legit
final he's gone I can get back into bed
and eat snacks all day
that was awesome so that's the first
level of the game I'm honestly so happy
with it they did an amazing job and you
bros are gonna love this game it's
coming this month we're announcing the
date in just a few days I start in 10
minutes I'm so nervous I can't eat their
stuff waiting for me outside that gate
it's gonna be another weird day god damn
it we just visited the Griffith
Observatory some secrets have happened
not about you a lot of weird spots today
what is he doing no one knows what is
that what the hell is going on I don't
even know it's a fat sick doing a lot of
weird [ __ ] today as well it wasn't as
bad as yesterday I feel feel pretty good
I don't even know if we're finished
they're not telling me anything I think
we're heading back now I hope because
I'm really tired and I gotta cross the
street Jesus Christ what is this okay I
don't know what's going on I'm just
sitting in a chair and I can't really
hear and I'm not allowed to like okay
and here we go I'm gonna fight on over
here I got something over your head you
can't see okay it's gonna be fine okay
I trust you guys I've got what the [ __ ]
just wrapped up can't show anything but
it's been pretty crazy pretty crazy by
pretty crazy I mean insane I should
summarize pretty well 9:15 we started at
12 today we'll save Marta's home
honey I'm hum yeah are you blogging - I
need a hug thanks for another day I wish
I could show more like I am workings I
don't want to keep pulling out my camera
and and in interrupt what I'm doing I'm
or what I'm not doing no one knows what
I'm doing leave a comment if you have a
guess of what I'm doing thank you both
so much for watching this vlog I will
see you tomorrow as always stay awesome
press Hey how's going I'm beautiful how
can you not know me